In the last video, we saw that
amines are actually reasonably
decent nucleophiles.
And, in particular, we saw some
ethylamine attack some
bromoethane in an
Sn2 reaction.
And right after that happened,
we had some diethylammonium
because the nitrogen had given
away an electron to this
carbon right over here.
So it had a positive charge.
And so you had diethylammonium
bromide.
The bromine had left,
taking an electron.
It then had a negative charge.
And then we said that that
could actually be in
equilibrium, where another
ethylamine goes and takes a
hydrogen from the
diethylammonium and turns that
into diethylamine.
So we essentially had a primary
amine turn into, or I
guess you could say, converted
into a secondary amine.
Now, the one thing that might
have popped into your brain
near the end of that video is,
hey, isn't this also a good
nucleophile?
And you say look, it's
got this lone pair.
It's more electronegative
than the things
that it's bonded with.
Maybe this too could do a
nucleophile attack or maybe
some type of an Sn2 reaction.
And you would be correct.
So you could imagine, if you
have some more bromoethane
hanging around-- let me draw
some more bromoethane.
So let me draw it like this.
So this is our bromo group.
And then let's say we have a
hydrogen above like that.
That's kind of upside down
from the last one we
did, but same idea.
Then we have another hydrogen
behind, just like that.
And this is obviously
a carbon.
You could imagine that now you
have this diethylamine.
It can have an Sn2 reaction
with the bromoethane.
So before it was just
the ethylamine.
Now it's the diethylamine
that's acting as a
nucleophile.
So this electron right here in
yellow could be given to this
carbon right at the same time
that this bromine leaves and
takes that electron.
And the bromine already had one,
two, three, four, five,
six, seven valence electrons.
And this is really almost
identical to what happened in
the previous video, except now
we are starting with a
secondary amine, and we're going
to see it's going to
turn into a tertiary amine, as
opposed to the last one, where
we started with a primary
amine and turned into a
secondary amine.
So what's this going
to look like after
we've done the attack?
So the bromine will have left.
It's now the bromide anion.
So now we have the
bromide anion.
It has its seven original
valence electrons and now it
took one more electron
from the carbon.
It now has a negative charge.
And now this ethane group right
here-- so this carbon
right here is this carbon right
over here-- is now going
to be attached-- let me
draw it this way.
It's now going to be attached
to this nitrogen.
So this yellow electron is now
attached to that carbon, and
it's bonded to that green
electron, which on the
nitrogen or that the
nitrogen has.
And then this nitrogen has two
other ethyl groups attached to
it, one, two, and then it also
has this hydrogen over here.
And because this nitrogen gave
away an electron, it now has a
positive charge.
And I didn't draw these two
hydrogens here on this carbon;
they're implicit.
I could draw them.
One hydrogen, one hydrogen,
and then another hydrogen.
But just to keep things simple,
I'm going to leave it
off, just so it becomes
very clear
that we now have triethyl.
Let me make this clear.
So we have one, two three
ethyl groups.
So now this is triethyl
and it's a
positively charged nitrogen.
It's bonded to four things.
And essentially, it has given
away an electron, so this is
triethylammonium.
And if you view it as being
an ionic compound with the
bromide, then you would call
this triethylammonium bromide,
which this would be the salt
version, the ionic compound
right there.
But we have our
triethylammonium, and then you
could imagine, we had
that ethylamine
floating around before.
If you still have enough of
that ethylamine floating
around-- so let me draw some
of that ethylamine.
Ethylamine looks like this.
It has two hydrogens.
It has a lone pair.
It has a slightly partially
negative charge right here.
Nitrogen is very
electronegative.
It's the most basic of the
neutral functional groups that
we've studied.
It might want to capture this
hydrogen proton, so it
captures it by giving
it its electron.
And then that electron that
was associated with that
hydrogen atom is now given
back to this nitrogen.
And now, once again, I'll draw
this as being in equilibrium.
I'll do this in equilibrium
because one could swipe the
hydrogen from the other.
But now this guy over here
becomes ethylammonium.
So I'll draw-- so this is
what he was before.
And now he's bonded
to this hydrogen.
So now he's bonded to this
green hydrogen over here.
Let me make this green
just here.
So that's ethylammonium.
And we saw this in the last
video: ethylammonium.
And then this guy right over
here, and, of course, you have
the bromide floating around, but
this guy over here now is
just a nitrogen bonded
to three ethyl
groups: one, two, three.
It lost its hydrogen, gained
an electron, so it's now
neutral again.
And so this guy is
triethylamine.
And since he gained that
electron, he had an electron
here, an electron there, so this
is the electron that he
already had and that magenta
electron he gets back, and he
has a lone pair.
So you might say, hey Sal, but
couldn't this guy, couldn't
triethylamine act as
a nucleophile?
And you would be right.
So the triethylamine, if you
still have some of that
bromoethane hanging around--
so let me draw some
bromoethane.
And obviously, there's
some hydrogen here.
There is some hydrogen here.
If you have some more of that
bromoethane hanging around,
this guy could then attack that
bromoethane and then you
would be left with-- what
would that look like?
Let me do it in that
same color.
So in that green color,
you have the nitrogen.
It has its three original ethane
groups or ethyl groups
that's attached to it.
It has this electron.
But it's now bonded to this
carbon over here.
And let me be very clear.
This was an Sn2 reaction.
So right when it attacks that
carbon, this bromine, and we
saw this multiple times, can
take that other electron from
the carbon, and so this becomes
another bromide anion.
I'm going a little bit faster
than I've done in the past
because we've seen this many,
many, many, many times.
And now this guy is attached
to this ethyl group.
So this ethyl group I could
just draw like this.
He gave this carbon, this
magenta electron there, and so
we have this new bond.
And I could also draw
the hydrogens.
We have this hydrogen
and this hydrogen.
We could draw them off like
this, hydrogen and hydrogen,
but that makes the drawing a
little bit more confusing.
But what just happened?
This guy gave away
an electron.
Let me make it clear.
He gave away an electron so he
has now a positive charge.
You have the bromine turned
into bromide.
It took an electron.
But what is this now?
This is tetraethylammonium.
So we have four.
It's a quaternary ammonium.
So this is tetra, tetra for
four: one, two, three, four.
Tetraethylammonium.
Ammonium, instead of amine,
because it has
that positive charge.
The nitrogen has four bonds.
It's given away an electron.
Tetraethylammonium, and then if
you view it as a salt with
the bromide anion, it's
tetraethylammonium bromide.
So the whole point of this video
and the last video is--
in the last video, I just wanted
to show you that an
amine, it's reasonably basic.
It can act as a nucleophile,
and show you how it would
react, show you the mechanism.
But what I wanted to show you
in this video is that that
reaction just keeps going.
And so when you start with the
original ingredients, when you
started with the ethylamine and
the bromoethane, you might
say, oh, this is
pretty simple.
You're just going to end
up with a little bit of
diethylamine.
But the reality is you're going
to end up with all of
this stuff.
It's going to be all mixed up
in every different way.
You're going to end up with some
diethylamine in there.
You're going to have some
ethylamine in there.
ammonium in there.
You'll have some
triethylammonium in there.
ethylammonium.
in there.
You're going to have a little
bit of everything.
Oh, let me be clear here.
I just want to make
sure I didn't
misname any of this stuff.
No.
Yes, I think I named it right.
Sometimes I get confused with
the ammoniums and amines.
But the whole point of this is
that this reaction can keep
going and this Sn2 reaction can
keep occurring in a bunch
of different ways.